so I do a little bit of teaching in the
area family business and I've done some
consulting work there and if I'm
teaching on this topic I will start off
by saying family business is it the best
of all possible worlds or recipe for
disaster and in a way that's kind of a
false question because the answer is
it's both of those things so family can
bring a huge amount of value to a
business it's just a high degree of
trust and I was in a business with my
brother for eight years and as I said
before plan a seldom works Plan B might
not work maybe by the time you get the
plan see you finally get the formula for
making the business work and in that
process of ups and downs there's all
sorts of opportunities for people to
lose interest or to act in their own
self-interest as opposed to the interest
of the business or the other parties so
having family members who you just
fundamentally trust that they won't that
they won't put their interest ahead of
yours is really helpful interestingly I
had a PhD student research the whole
issue of traveling family trusts and
family businesses and what she found is
that that the trust amongst the top
management team in a family business
actually increased from the first
generation to the second generation in a
way that kind of makes sense because the
second generation is a group that's
grown up in the business the sort of
tendency of entrepreneurs founder
entrepreneurs to be paranoid and
micromanagers dissipates and you can
have more of a team-based approach by
the second generation but that after the
second generation as the ownership gets
more dispersed as people with maybe less
contact irrelevant skills with the
business come in family business trust
amongst the top management team and
family businesses falls off fairly
dramatically
and by the time of the gift to the
fourth generation it's it's sort of a
free fall